All right, guys, so here is example number one. So if you are confused, what is this? This is an indicator. So go to indicators type in
quarterly
cycles
By this theory and this is by alt many it has one four eight zero reviews
Once you have that you can go ahead and copy my settings
So it's gonna hide I disable these and I also disable the labels to make the chart clean now over here
What do we have we you see these big boxes and then we have small boxes so the big boxes are the
Quarters and the small boxes are the quadrants in each quarter
Now the auto flow is clearly bearish here
We broke this structure went down broke this structure and went down
Now focus on the red box and the red quadrant here if I zoom in a bit here what you can see is we have
a sweep of this high over here
This is a liquidity perch right we slightly went above
Here, but we didn't take out this but we took out this liquidity here. So that is important
After we took out the liquidity what you can see is we have a shift in the market structure
during the expansion phase of the
quarter
Now what we do have here is an auto block
And price as you can see during the expansion phase during the
Manipulation phase of the expansion quarter. So the red box of the expansion or you could say distribution
We went into the PDRA
So this could have been your entry and you could have targeted somewhere around here
So a very simple trading strategy guys and
Oops my bad
Right there
So if I go in somewhere around here
All right, perfect. I think this should be example number one. Let's move on to the next example